[Music]
hello everyone we're going to talk about
microphones I'm Christian I do IOT stuff
react stuff I think that's enough about
me I'm Chris Young
just call me Christian or moody COO
whatever I'm Almer I am from the
developer at Brandel you can check it
out there you can read articles online
there you can reach me with via
different channels but we have not said
that you have time
Grendel is cool check Len loud ok let's
talk about micro front ends and reasons
why you might want to introduce micro
front ends and what microphone that's
are and how to implement them and who
else you had ever heard of micro front
ends and is interested in it that's
quite a few is one of you working with
Nylund holy that's like for people
you're gonna recognize some stuff ok why
are we talking about micro front ends
micro front ends our topic - or an
answer to the question how do we
structure the development of our web
applications there's some traditional
approaches on how to do that the most
traditional and most common or oldest or
whatever approach is this if we develop
an online shop we have one monolithic
application that handles everything it
contains our HTML or JavaScript CSS PHP
Java whatever you do in the backend
that's just one team that develops this
application at some point someone might
have realized ok the team is getting
bigger and structuring it as one team
and one application doesn't really work
out so well so people start to split it
up and the easiest way and the most
obvious way to structure or just split
up a development team is to realize okay
we have back-end developers we have
front-end developers let's make it back
and team in a front-end team who of you
is working in this team setting it's the
most ok interesting at some point some
of the back-end problems might become
bigger and the back-end team quite often
becomes the bigger team and at someone
you have like 500 developers and 25
back-end developers and then you realize
them again we're having a team of 25
people and that doesn't scale so
you start to split up the back end and
there's this microservice thing that
people have been doing for ages now or
even before that they call it
service-oriented architecture and that
was basically the same but hmm okay so
this is a very very naive approach to
say okay the back-end team becomes
bigger so let's split it up but I don't
know if you know the year but it's 2018
and maybe we're having a front-end
application that requires more than
three or five developers but maybe we
have a front-end team of like 20
developers or maybe we've heard of the
term that was called cross-functional
teams where we say we should not split
up the team and a product management
team and a designer team in a front-end
team and a back-end team but instead
have a team for every part of our
application for every part of our
business domain and that's why in some
at some point people started to use a
different approach this is sometimes
referred to as self-contained systems
which comes from the DDD world
never mind that part but the approach
here is to say okay we have a team for
instance if we were talking about a web
shop team inspire they are responsible
for suggestions of new products we have
a team search they're responsible for
the search team check out obvious what
they do and the team is responsible for
both the front-end part the backend part
the everything that's there the product
management part that's one team by the
way I asked about Nolan before Nolan did
this website micro front-ends org this
picture is from microfarad and ster org
didn't it say it's on when the slides it
was on the first slide well sorry I
forgot to mention mentioned that it's an
open license that why we can use it it's
cool website so we didn't make up the
term micro front and I think Nolan
didn't either but yeah they made this
cool website the question is why do we
want to do something like this I
mentioned reasons for it but there are
several reasons why you want to do this
exactly one reason is that what you
mentions the team is growing and you
have too much developers in one team and
you have to split up to work you can do
it by either making a lot of Trello
cards or JIRA tickets or something like
that and let developers work on
different domains but this don't often
work out very well because you have
all domain knowledge needed another
reason could be that you want to deploy
your product or your front-end or your
product separately this could be a
reason that you have differents vzf
different sprints times and you want to
release more often for example but your
main product is released once in a month
then you can split up the front ends and
you can deploy the products separately
another idea could be that you want to
isolate your run time this could be very
different reasons for example you have a
payment service and you have to collect
special day to form a payments of
payment service provider and you have
conflicts with normal us privacy but for
a payment you have to do it so this
could be also a valid approach and the
most or I think the most important i've
reason to to split up michael front-ends
is that you have one legacy application
and you want to modernize it but you
don't want to do a big band migration
that you have to throw away all the code
and rewrite everything with the
microphones and you can modernize the
application piece by piece and then you
have one small part that is new and the
big legacy part and you can migrate this
big application step by step but the
question is if we have reasons how to do
it how do we actually do that there are
several approaches that we want to
mention but the question is we now have
a problem what's the obvious solution
these days always the same blockchain is
always the solution to every problem
right we're missing a blockchain talk at
this conference I mentioned it before
not that I'm a fan of it ok no getting
serious again what are solutions on how
to implement micro front-ends one way is
to have a short shared we run time where
many front ends run within the same
runtime or we can I say every front-end
has its own runtime there's also like a
mixed approach that we're going to talk
about
let's get started with the own runtime
how do we separate rent times of
applications well we're in the web and
there's a technology that's pretty cool
we just reinvent the wheel and yeah use
hyperlinks so we have one application
that is called in our shop example the
inspire page so we have a website let's
say inspired the shop calm and on that
page we can see new products than we
have searched the shop comm and we can
find products there and then there's the
product website products dot the shop
comm the first two just link to these
products that the shop comm one approach
the you see very often in web shops is
that you also have a payment page
separately because you ran through the
checkout process you come to the payment
point and then you do one special thing
in one of these runtimes in one of these
front ends and that's actually pretty
cool because the runtimes are completely
separated I mean in a case of an online
shop let's be honest that probably
doesn't work that well I can tell you we
at blend will have done exam it's
exactly this example we have put out our
payment service into our payment page
into a different front end it was quite
a big work but now it's a huge benefit
to half exactly this set up again for
blender it makes sense I think it's a
payment you said also landing pages
right
are separate exactly they're completely
separate from the rest of the
application so it makes sense to take
them out because then it's easier to to
decide okay with the landing pages we
want to use the next big thing in web
technology and that's what you exactly
did right yeah we used next yes so the
next yes you have different approaches
and you have different goals to achieve
with each project for a landing page
project for example you want to achieve
the best marketing possible so you want
fast patron rings you want server-side
rendered server-side rendering but you
don't want it in your big application
very users authenticate because it makes
so much headache to implement this and
then you can skip it for a payment
service you have completely different
things you want to use so different
projects and different goals to achieve
but again the reality is not always like
this
right so there might be situations where
we have different teams developing
different micro front-ends and this all
should be on the same page so we want to
have multiple applications running
within the same page and again thanks to
Nolan for that image
what we have here is a webshop and let's
say that this webshop is developed
consists of multiple microphones we have
the Buy button here that's from one a
flip application the green box is
obviously from team inspire because
they're responsible for the gist
suggesting new products to customers and
then the outside is well team product
again I think you're not supposed to
retweets why we do talk sorry if we have
an approach like this if we have a
website like this and we split our
team's like we suggest it before all
these teams have to run within the same
scope of the other website and this
might work if we have for instance a
team that does react the team that does
angular a team that does view Jas then
we could run this all in the same
application in the same Dom in the same
JavaScript scope and it might actually
work there might be some obvious
problems that we're going to talk about
later but you could do that if you
instead have multiple versions of the
same framework say react 14 15 and 16
and you run them on the same page you
might run into problems because they all
want to define the global called react
or some libraries they're used the same
global variables that actually happen to
us with a react multi-micro from an
application and they had the same
version of react but still have problems
and then there's a way on how we could
actually implement such a page that
consists of multiple front micro
front-end applications by just putting
iframes there that's something I was
expecting laughter that's fine
the thing is high friends might not be
as bad as you think
i frames used to be very bad and we
hated them I mean frames used to be even
worse right but there might be reasons
why we would want to use my iframes here
they're perfect because they give us the
separation of if like if we would run on
multiple domains we can actually run on
multiple domains but just include them
with the iframes so it feels to the user
like they're using one big application
but in truth you have multiple
applications of course if you have like
20 iframes that include 20 other iframes
that include ten other iframes you might
run into problems of course but if it's
just what you mentioned before the
payment and you have the payment button
that should be included with one other
application then it's totally fine at
least if they don't have bundle sizes of
20 megabytes no application should have
that of course right so again if you can
do the iframes that's a super cool
approach because you can integrate it's
for the user it feels like it's one
application but in truth we have
completely separate runtimes that's you
okay yeah so if we want to achieve
exciting is this example of different
versions of on tools on one page this is
possible actually right now in the
browser
imagine we use a tool that we all have
in our hands or on our laps like a
browser and we all know HTML or at least
we know a little bit of HTML and in HTML
we have something that is called input
input with a type date/time local will
cause I couldn't make a screenshot of it
but it will make a calendar to choose a
time and a date with this tiny piece of
code it will look like something like
that what if we can take this approach
to something for our micro front-end
idea that we just have an element we can
play somewhere for example check out
button and use it in the place we want
to use it in the shared runtime so we
can define our own elements with an I
hope it is a little bit readable with an
API that is called custom element
actually the custom element version one
is most
it's implemented in Chrome and in Safari
also on iOS and it's about to be
implemented or nearly ready it's hidden
behind a flag for Firefox and it will be
implemented in etch you can define
elements by yourself if you ever have
done angular version one you maybe know
how to define an element it's nearly the
same here you define a class with a
constructor which will be which will be
called one year when you use the element
and you just define the elements that
you want to that you want be used with
this you can it's nearly not readable
you can put properties into it
and just use the HTML element and that
means behind that okay now I know why
you wanted to fall down here behind this
element you can hide whether it's a
react application whether it's a angular
application whether that's you element
whatever you can just encapsulate it in
a custom element and then no one will
know what you use behind the scenes and
you can change the implementation
completely as long as you stick with
this contract and the good thing is you
can hide everything behind this element
is that you can use a completely
different at the framework I mean we all
do JavaScript and we all use plenty of
frameworks so I want to introduce a new
framework that's called stencil stencil
j/s is built by the ionic team and it's
exactly what it it's exactly for custom
elements made so it uses the web
component or the custom element api
under the hood with the concepts that
look like angular and that looks like
react so if you have angular if you have
done angular this code will look like
angular for you and if you have done
react it will look like react for you
you define the tag and you can define
styles and everything and everything is
included it's also fully reactive so if
you change the property it will react to
it it has a virtual Dom implementation
all the cool implemented it is
written in typescript and you can
compile it it's really awesome we have
it in production since yesterday at
Lendl so I can really recommend this
tool it also has is it
also can come with server-side rendered
for applications but you don't have to
use something like stand so for this
component things you just can use the
tools you have already like Christian
said you can use react or angular
angular version greater to house will
come with angular element that use
completely the same ok so we mentioned
on why would you do that how do we do
that what our implementation details but
for us it's always important if we talk
about something to mention what are the
downsides because even if we have to
scale a team and micro fragments might
help us everything comes at a cost one
obvious thing which you probably got
when I was talking about the iframe
within the iframe within the iframe a
bundle sizes it might be a problem
obviously if you start rendering within
one page multiple applications in
iframes or using using custom elements
but one of them uses react and the other
uses angular you have big bundle sizes
that might be a problem it might be okay
if you're like developing Spotify and
you have to download it Spotify up
anyways it doesn't matter whether it's
contains five megabytes of react and
five megabytes of angular because people
are going to stream a lot of music with
it anyway so who cares it also depends
on the approach that you take if you
have like Lendl does that the shared
runtimes the payment page that you
wizard like once a month maybe and the
landing page that you only visit once in
your lifetime probably and then the real
blender application it doesn't really
matter if all of them have a bundle size
of five megabytes because you usually
only use one of them it does matter
especially for a landing page for
marketing but it's sorry if you have
something like serviceworker for your
main application for your core
application it doesn't matter that much
also if you're doing one of this shared
runtime approaches one thing that I
mentioned before we are having this
react application that actually consists
of multiple react
what we do there is that most of the
react libraries are only loaded once
because we just used the same version of
react or a router react whatever so we
only have to load them once so that
makes stuff better you can you can
improve stuff there but you should take
a lot of care obviously and yeah I
mention it before if you're doing the
iframe approach things might get very
very dirty very very early because if
you're bootstrap multiple applications
on the same page that's gonna be a lot
of bundles also it's gonna be a lot of
memory because you're gonna have ten
instances of react and five instances of
angular and five instances of you
running on the same page so I don't know
old cheap Android phones and all cheap
iPhones might might have problems there
again there might be situations where it
works like the Spotify player I
mentioned before all these service
workers which might have as well one big
problem is consistent look and feel if
you have like ten teams they're
developing ten front-ends and they're
somehow integrated like with iframes or
however they however you want to
integrate them even with a shared
runtime approach if team a decides okay
that button becomes green now and has
been blue forever
the rest of the replication probably
still has the blue one that might be a
problem so the question is now what do
we do to make sure that the button
always has the same color
one approach that actually in a ten yet
a conference mentioned to us like two
weeks ago three weeks ago it's pretty
straightforward we just don't care
because the user won't care if the okay
button is sometimes green and sometimes
blue there's this American startup in
e-commerce there called something like
Amazon I don't know if it's a river yeah
yeah sorry if you look at their webpage
it's unbelievable inconsistent go to the
settings or even worse go to Amazon
business settings and everything looks I
don't know like an HTML page that's 15
years old so there might be reasons
might be situations where you just have
to you can ignore it and maybe
you make the button green at the other
applications five month later that's
fine yes
some different start apps like face
Facebook weather also change buttons
often or or glasses no Google is it
Google also have different buttons on
different pages if you dive deeper into
an UI I mean if you ever have used
analytics Google Analytics page it's the
hell of inconsistence UI but it just
works and it makes a lot of money right
so it can't be that bad but of course we
have like real solutions that are not
saying ignore it another projection we
skip that shared CSS thing right yeah
I'm gonna say that you can have one big
CSS file for all your microphone that's
if you're good at CSS I'm not but if
you're good at it you can do that
something just like bootstrap is doing
you have one CSS and we use the class
names everywhere but another approach is
to have a component library a UI
component library you can use the
microphone that idea and the custom
element idea to build reusable
components just we saw earlier with the
input element you can build your your
your check out button your company check
out button in a shared component library
and reuse the same UI everywhere in
every project the nice thing is you
don't have to reinvent the wheel every
time you have a dialog component any of
your main components your main UI
components somebody find also this helps
to communicate with designers then you
have one file a kind of style guide
where everything is defined and if a
designer comes around with a new design
you just can use the existing ones and
check with him maybe to use existing
ones that's actually something that's
very very easy if you use the same
framework within every of your micro
micro front-ends because then you can
just like expose react components in
your UI component library or you can
expose angular elements in the UI
component library if you're mixing it
again it gets more complicated
but we heard about the custom elements
API before so I think you can do it even
if you have different libraries just
keep in mind that if you have a shared
libraries that you want to be sure that
the version of your library we don't
have breaking changes because when it
wants you change the API of your UI
elements every other microphone and will
break and you have to fix it manually
that's why I would always say if you're
developing such a component library have
like the strictest code review process
in place for this library and just like
an open-source library use semantic
versioning do not break PC like ever and
if you do talk to every team that uses
the library that's the only place where
you're allowed to break PC in these in
these component libraries and use tools
to automatically update your
dependencies and to check the
dependencies I've heard it in every talk
I was today it was - is you something
like greenkeeper or something like
renovate to automatically check put in
pull requests into your codebase once
the dependency updates it's also the
same for own dependencies use a UI
component for as a module and
automatically update them one thing I
want to mention I said take care of that
it's that there's a strict code review
process in place for changes to the
component library there's a problem if
you make it too hard to update the
component library to add new stuff to
the component library people would just
implement the components within their
micro front end and not contribute it
back to your shared component library so
that's really something that's not gonna
be easy once you have a component
library you should build something like
a kitchen sink a component library
example page you can use something like
style guide is if you're using react or
you can use storybook if you're using
polymer or web components react or
angular Union or view is also you think
it's okay if you use one of the major
frameworks then your storybook both of
these tools are awesome and can help in
the progress a process also you can show
every case that is possible with your
component one thing we're talking about
sharing code here between multiple
microphone that's using a component
library and some people will tell you if
you
doing micro front ends or micro-services
or self-contained systems or whatever do
not share code between them so do not
create a component library like this we
disagree with this there are things that
you shouldn't care share I think in the
self-contained system world people are
very agree on the fact that you should
not share business code but stuff like
UI components as long as they don't
contain business logic that's fine or
tooling that should be fine as well you
don't want to implement uses a user
query every time in every project in
every microphone that you have you want
reusable stuff for this yes there's one
thing my favorite topic that I always
rage about when I talk about JavaScript
who a few likes to maintain web page
configuration files there are people who
like that like four of them or five
sorry yeah the thing is if you hate
configuring them maintaining them like I
do I really hate that you know I have to
do that like 17 times right because you
know I have seventeen microphone ends so
you really have to invest into cheap
tooling you mentioned greenkeeper before
that's very very good to have that also
if you don't use maybe you use different
package manager in different projects
maybe you have got maybe you have roll
up maybe you have grunt maybe you have
next big thing JSP parcel I don't know
you can use all of them belt make
contracts between teams that you use the
same tools for every project you have
that might make sense because otherwise
yeah
knowledge will be spread completely
weird one important thing you have to
think about is routing between front
ends we just mentions that you have to
that we reinvented hyperlinks between
different Dom States also if you
navigate from one to another
Micro front-end you want to preload
stuff so you want to make sure that it
is working in a correct way just on the
client side but also you have you want
to have something on the server sides
that make routing to different front
ends on different paths it's much more
easily
easier you can use something simple like
engine eggs or an express server for
that but they are complicated more
complicated stuff out there you can use
that you find it if you search for
routing or microformats and obviously if
you're using like a shared runtime
approach where you're using react view
and angular on the same page you can't
just use angular router because yeah you
also need to support direct route to
somehow or you develop your own router
because developing your own library is
always a good idea right irony Thanks
okay so again the conclusion microphone
ends might help you big time we have
kind of different opinions on one when
you want to introduce micro fragments
for me it's always a question of if your
team is getting too big then they might
really really help you if you're
modernizing applications like mi just
mentioned then it's really a big help we
can because even if you have this big
old XJ s3 application that some
companies still have you can someone is
laughing not the one I was talking to
actually he didn't start laughing okay
then you can just start developing your
new components with react and integrate
them to your old application or do it
the way that blender does this all works
and it helps you a lot but it comes at a
cost again 17 webpack configs right so
always introduce new micro front ends
with care I've seen projects that have
like 10 to 15 micro front ends for like
three front end developers that usually
hurts a lot so take care when you
introduce new micro front ends just be
sure that you don't implement or just
adds new complexity too because it's
cool to have micro front ends right now
always check if it's needed and mostly
it's when you want to modernize your
applications then it's a really good way
to add new micro front ends don't forget
if you modernize to throw away old code
that's the most important thing always
keep in mind that throwing away code
should be the best way when you review a
code make sure that the code is
removable later on this will help if you
want to implement micro front ends once
in a time maybe in five years so if you
use microphones for like you mentioned
the
legacy or the modernizing of legacy
applications and you start with the
extras monolith and start the new react
application there if you then decide
okay we want to go with view jeaious
then maybe don't set up the third
microphone and with view J's but try to
get rid of one of the others first I'll
just start a new micro front-end with
react because you have it already all
right miss x3 s3 that's actually all of
our content I think we have like three
four minutes left for questions are
there any questions about this topic
there's one yes I didn't get that word
how do you synchronize what yes that's
an interesting thing that's actually
something that I just experienced in an
application where people had problems
with that so what we do is we have quite
a lot of events flowing between the
iframe and the outer regions so we have
for this this placeholder image that's
rendered before the actual content of
the four iframes rendered and at some
point the iframe is gonna send a okay
I'm done rendering and then the image is
replaced with the content of the real
iframe does that somehow answer your
question great other questions or do you
want to add something sorry no how do
you share what state state yeah if you
want to share a state you always want to
make sure that it's the lowest level
possible
mostly it's something like a refresh
token or a jpg and you want to build up
the state by your own because you have
your own state management library in
every other language if you have one
state management library for multiple
languages something like Redux or
something like mopix
then it's possible to use the same state
library and just swap out the UI part it
heavily depends but mostly you want to
go down as much as possible and don't
share any stage between them that's
exactly exactly what I wanted to say so
you mentioned JSON web tokens or let's
say the information has to be about the
current user you may share that state if
you want to share more state then
probably these
should not be two different microphones
because they're responsible for the same
business domain so they should actually
be one application how do you make them
communicate with each other it totally
depends on the approach so if it's the
iframe approach you can just use this
postmessage api is that the name I think
it's the name yes if it's in the shared
runtime you can have them Central even
passed there what we're doing with a
separate runtime thing is that we have a
even pass in the backend and some of the
events are actually transferred to the
front end using WebSockets so that I can
communicate using that what's important
there from my point of view is have a
defined contract on what is allowed as a
communication I experience one project
they just through Redux messages Redux
actions into the Redux message bus and
nowhere there was any documentation
about the messages someone just assumed
okay if the message is called
at user then there's probably this
property that's gonna be a hell so if
you communicate with each other define a
contract there there is also a good
library from Zendesk
it's called shared shared storage it's
something like local storage but for
different domains x''b all which works
very good for if you have different
runtimes I think and there's one last
question
what is Universal renderings that back
into the server-side rendering in front
and rendering I'm not sure right now
yeah if you have I want to have
universal rendering you have to say with
one framework and you can't mix the
different front ends in between that's
more integrated in the web server like
if you have an express server then you
could do weird stuff there you can do
weird stuff but it's hard and yet it's
minimal work it's not really something
that that works out of the boxes like
react render or view of angular or I
don't know if there are further
questions we're gonna be here the whole
day we're gonna be at the party tonight
just come to us talk to us talk to us on
Twitter I think our names are there yes
they are so thanks a lot and have a lot
of fun at the JSON conf
[Applause]
[Music]